welcome to the presentation on dividing
decimals let's get started with the
problem if I were to say how many times
is 0.28 go into twenty three point eight
two eight eight two eight so you're
going to see that these dividing
decimals problems we're actually just
like the level for division problems and
you just have to figure out where to put
the decimal so what you do is you always
want to take this decimal and move it
over as many spaces as necessary to turn
this number into a whole number so in
this case you have to move it one space
two spaces over to put the decimal here
well if I did that with this number I
have to do it with this number as well
so I moved it over two spaces to rights
have to move this decimal two spaces to
the right one two decimal goes here and
I put the decimal right above right
there now I can treat this 28 as a whole
number and if I want to let me see if I
could well I want to raise the old
decimal because if you're doing it with
a pen you would kind of have the same
problem I have so now we do it just like
a level 4 division problem so we say how
many times does 28 go into - well no
times the 2 is smaller than 28 how many
times just 28 go into 23 once again
still it goes into it zero times because
23 is smaller than 28 how many times 28
go into 238 so let's think about that 28
is almost 30 238 is almost 240 so 30
goes into 248 times because 3 goes into
24 eight times so I'm going to guess
that it goes the 28 goes into 238 eight
times and it literally is a guess you
have to try out some numbers some times
8 times 8 is 64 8 times 2 is 16 plus 2
is 22
subtract I get four teen guests right
because the remainder when I go when I
divide 28 into 238 and I say it goes
into eight times is 14 which is less
than 28
so 8 was the largest number of times so
the 28 could go into 238 without being
larger so now I bring down this 2 once
again as you recognize this is just
purely a level 2 division problem I
level a level 4 division problem so now
I say how many times is 28 go into 142
well once again I'm going to approximate
28 it's almost 30 30 let's see 30 times
4 is 120
so yeah I'll take a guess and I'll say
let's say it goes into it 4 times I
could be wrong but let's see if it works
out 4 times let me get rid of this old 6
4 times 8 is 32 and 4 times 2 is 8 plus
3 is 11 2 minus 2 is 0 4 minus 1 is 3
huh interesting so it turns out that my
remainder here is larger than 28 so I
actually could have divided 28 into 142
one more time so let me go back and
change that see it's it's it's it's not
a mechanical thing and if you feel
unsure sometimes you just have to try
numbers and see if they work and
otherwise you raise or lower the number
accordingly so let me erase that for let
me erase that form and try not to mess
up ready step 4
erase all this stuff down here I
probably should have tried it out on the
side first before doing all this and I
wouldn't have had to go back and erase
it erase all this and then let me get
back to what I was doing so when I went
it to it four times the remainder was
too large so let me try 5 now 5 times 8
is 40 and 5 times 2 is 10 plus 4 is 14
142 - 140 is too good - is less than 28
this five is correct now I just bring
down the 8 28 goes into 28 exactly one
time one times 28 is 28 ranger zero done
so 28 goes into two thousand three
hundred eighty two point eight eighty
five point one times or you could say
point two eight goes into twenty three
point eight - eight eighty five point
one times that's the answer we had
gotten and that makes sense it's always
good to do a reality check because if I
took eighty five point one and I
multiply it by 0.28 it makes sense that
I'd get a number around twenty three
point two eights
almost 1/3 so 23 is almost 1/3 of 85 so
at least it makes sense in rough numbers
when you're doing decimals if I had
gotten 800 here instead of 85 I'd be
like Oh - eight times eight hundred I
don't know if that equals 23 so it's
always good to just do a reality check
and get a sense for at least the
magnitude of what your answer should be
let's do another problem
let's do three point three goes into
forty three point two three that's a
three so first thing we want to do is
move the decimal we just have to move it
one space here so we move it one space
here as well put the decimal right up
here and now it's just a level 4
division problem 33 goes into 4 zero
times forty 33 goes into forty three one
time that's easy one times 33 is 33 do
the subtraction 43 - 33 is 10 bring down
this - 33 goes into 102 you could
eyeball that one say Oh three times
because you know three times 33
nine three times 33 is 99 102 minus 99
let's easy that's three we just bring
down this three thirty three goes into
33 one time one times 33 is 33 33 0 so
three point three goes into forty three
point two three thirteen point one times
or if you move the decimal over and when
you move the decimal over to the right
one spot all you're doing is you're
multiplying both the divisor and the
dividend by 10 and which is fine as long
as you multiply both of them by ten so
when you it's also like saying 33 goes
into four hundred thirty two point three
thirteen point one times let's do one
more problem I think I have time YouTube
puts a limit on this stuff so let's say
I say two point five goes into point
three three five zero how many times
well once again let's move the decimal
point over one here so we move the
decimal point over one here put the
decimal here so how many times does 25
go into three well zero so you can just
you can put a zero here just for fun if
you want how many times does 25 go into
thirty three what goes into it one time
one times 25 is 25 33 minus 25 is eight
bring down the five 25 goes into 85 well
we know 25 times 3 is 75 so 25 so it'll
go into 3 times 3 times 25 we know
that's 75 85 minus 75 is 10 bring down
this 0 up here we had brought down to 5
before and 25 goes into 100 four times
so our answer is two point five goes
into 0.335 zero point one three four
times so as you see the only different
step between what we're doing in when
we're dividing decimals and
between and when we're doing level 4
division is we just have to make sure we
get the decimal in the right place and
that's just you shift the decimal here
enough so that this becomes a whole
number and you have to just have to
shift the decimal here the same number
of times and once you do that it just
becomes a level 4 division problem and
the whole trick with level 4 division is
always be willing to try numbers and if
the numbers don't work adjust them
accordingly don't feel that there should
be a way that you can just always power
through these problems you have to do a
little bit of trial and error and maybe
use your eraser or do some work on the
side every now and then but anyway I
think you're ready to do some dividing
decimals problems I hope you have some
fun